hold on to your brothers and sisters and
let a hobo into your house because we
have the most thrilling movie about a
mother since psycho when I send my
ex-wife for alimony you can lick the
stamped Netflix's I am mother is the
story of daughter a young girl raised by
a robot to help repopulate the earth
following mankind's extinction so in
this video we're gonna take a deep dive
into the ending and explain some of the
hidden clues buried throughout the film
to understand the ending we must first
take a look at mother and her
motivations why is it that she only
raises one human when there are
thousands of other embryos waiting to be
grown the excuse she gives daughter is
that she needs more time to learn to be
a mother before growing the others which
honestly is a pretty weak response and
has never brought up again mothers need
time to learn raising a good child but
the real reason is far more sinister and
if you pay close attention you can
figure it out before the big reveal at
the very beginning were introduced to
the UN you hwk repopulation facility
which hosts 63,000 human embryos it's
here on day one that mother grows her
first child we then fast forward
thirteen thousand eight hundred and
sixty seven days later where we follow
the story of daughter but that's over 37
years and daughter is only 18 what
happened during those missing 19 years
as daughter finds out mother raised at
least two other children before her
embryos ap X 1 & 2 daughter is number 3
by breaking into the lab she finds that
ap X 2 was 7 years old when she was
aborted and that her failure rate was
74% her body was then disposed of in the
incinerator where daughter later finds
her teeth if you rewind to the very
beginning and check the incubator you
can see this is not daughter that is
being made but rather a px oh one
roughly 19 years before daughter is even
born the beginning is edited in such a
way as to manipulate us into thinking
we're watching daughter grow up
this whole ruse is a result of mother's
programming to create a smarter more
ethical perfect human that will replace
old humanity with the new and this giant
plan began on the day of the
quote-unquote extinction event in the
very beginning as mother is being put
together we can hear the bomb
things happening outside the bunker as
the camera shakes and lights flicker on
and off not much is known about this
event and what little info we do get
about the history of the outside world
comes in little snippets from woman who
we'll meet later on our best guess is
that this was some sort of war between
the droids and humanity likely involving
nuclear or chemical attacks since woman
said nothing would grow for years and
that the air was difficult to breathe
this all changed six months earlier when
droid ships came out of nowhere and
began growing fields of crops as will
later learn the droids are preparing the
earth for the new humans while
systematically hunting down the
remaining ones to make way for the new
world but mother's plan is far more
intricate we learned that she shares a
single consciousness with all of the
droids when she knew daughter was a
viable candidate to start this new world
a message was sent to the droids
above-ground to set up the world for
repopulation and because she can share
this consciousness a droid with the same
mother voice visits woman in her shelter
by the beach at the end of the movie
it's he or she tells woman something
very interesting stating Harris isn't
that you've survived so long where
others have not as if someone's out of
purpose for you this suggests that when
woman first visits the bunker it was all
part of mother's plan to get daughter to
see the real violent lying old humanity
and mother's plan works the end of the
movie sees daughter entering the embryo
chamber ready to wake up her brothers
and sisters to repopulate the earth she
has in essence become the new mother the
title I am mother isn't referring to the
robot it's referring to the daughter who
at the end picks up this metaphoric
mantle old humanity is not only
encapsulated in the character of woman
but also her belief in a mother of a
different sort Mary Mother of Jesus
woman holds a rosary has religious
paraphernalia in her shelter and tells
daughter before she leaves it's no sin
looking after yourself the story goes
that the Virgin Mary gave birth to Jesus
through Immaculate Conception and Jesus
would go on to renew the world
technically daughter was also born of a
virgin this weird spherical gestation
chamber and her purpose is also to renew
the world religion aside its philosophy
that plays a dominant role in daughter's
world one of the most important scenes
of the film occurs when daughter is
confronted with the lesson of the organ
patients you have two choices the first
kill one healthy patient to harvest
their organs to save the five others or
second let the one healthy patient live
while the others who come to their
ailments it's this question that guides
mother's philosophy about life for
mother it's okay to destroy the entire
world if it will mean more people will
flourish in the future this idea of new
worlds is also explored in the books
found throughout the movie like Dorothy
and The Wizard of Oz and the character
of John Carter in Edgar Rice Burroughs
the gods of Mars we also can't forget
the origami the art of shaping paper
into whatever you want just like how
mother shapes daughter into what she
wants and this is why mother ultimately
lets daughter kill her even holding up
the gun towards her processor she is
shaped daughter into the woman she is
today and knows she is ready to take on
the task of repopulating the world she
also knows that woman likely the last of
the humans is now taken care of the
world is finally ready
to start anew overall I am mother makes
us question if it's okay to do bad
things if it means more good will come
of it
it makes us question with the meaning of
motherhood of humanity for that matter
but at the end of the day you need to
ask yourself would you save that one
patient or would you save the five would
you side with mother or would you go on
your own path thanks for watching
everyone if you like this video please
make sure to LIKE and subscribe I have
more videos on the way and you can reach
me on Twitter at things story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much